die engländerin hat allen grund beide
menschen aus ihrem leben zu verbannen
denn ihre eigene mutter julie hat lauren
den mann ausgespannt
was soll man dazu sagen heute das
einzige was ihm dazu einfällt ist doch
wirklich herzlich kommt sondern bedeute
ich werde wieder für euch da und ja ich
habe mir überlegt im vorfeld des videos
ob ich heute zum einstieg ein witz
machen sollten über die aktuelle
situation und darüber dass ich auch
nicht zum friseur gehen kann wie auch
sonst keiner und degas es ist wirklich
einfach
es ist nicht witzig gibt die durch das
mal leute meine seiten sind mittlerweile
wirklich auf 81 ja auf jeden fall leute
war ich hatte es auf youtube unterwegs
und da habe ich am rande so ein video
vorgeschlagen gesehen und hab ich mir
gedacht es kommt noch sony de wieder wie
soll ist doch hilft mir ne das ist keine
hilfe mehr leute wünschen uns heute das
video horror mutter spannend tochter den
mann aus und bekommt drei kinder mit ihm
und ja wir legen es das 1 1 nur noch
wenige fotos besitzerin von ihrem ex
ehemann und ihre mutter
ok also diese lauren das ist scheinbar
schon die tochter war die ist jetzt auch
nicht mehr so ganz auf der ganz jungen
das leben das ich bin auch schon seit 30
oder so das macht das ganze wirklich
nicht besser
das heißt ihre mutter mit der ihr mann
durchgebrannt ist ist dann wie alt 60
das ist doch wirklich scheiße
die engländerin hat allen grund beide
menschen aus ihrem leben zu verbannen
denn ihre eigene mutter julie hat lauren
den mann ausgespannt
also was soll man dazu sagen heute das
einzige was einem dazu einfällt ist doch
wirklich das muss hilft mir sein
die haben es einfach auf dem falschen
kanal hochgeladen ist es auf dem kanal
hochgeladen ist kann nicht sein also
versteht was ich meine leute dass man so
was macht das war es war auf die geht
die idee überhaupt kommt so etwas zu
machen und dass man es dann tatsächlich
durchzieht wie kann das sein dass man
sich zwischendrin nicht denkt dicker was
mache ich hier gerade alles beginnt vor
15 jahren damals sind paul und die heute
34 jährige lauren aus ihrer sicht
glücklich verheiratet leute man muss es
wirklich
also bevor wir jetzt noch mehr nähere
details werden muss man sich allein mal
die situation vorstellen ok-chef ohr für
alle mädels da draußen ich habe einen
großteil mädels als zuschauer okay ich
stelle euch jetzt vor hier bringt einen
freund nach hause okay ihr habt einen
neuen freund ihr liebt den geförderten
super es folgt ein cooler typ sowie
möglichen bringt er mit nach hause und
stellt in eurer mutter vater und dann
cloud euch eure mutter ihren freund
verlassen wird geht man zu seiner mutter
aber ich habe meinen ehemann an meine
mutter verloren es hat mich doppelt
getroffen ich habe niemanden
normalerweise verlassen wir lieber zu
seiner mutter
ihre mutter soll jetzt mal 90 leute aus
einer ernsten perspektive gesprochen da
sieht man schon dass in dieser familie
ist nicht mit rechten dingen zugehen
kann da das stimmt irgendetwas nicht
irgendwelche intrigen oder geistigen
verwirrung sind deinbus kein normaler
mensch kommt auf so eine idee des das
passiert in keiner normalen familie und
paul kennen sich aus der schule sie
heiraten früh und bekommen gleich ein
baby lorenz zu diesem zeitpunkt 19 jahre
alt versucht hilfe und rat bei ihrer
namen julie und fassbar es ist wirklich
unfassbar leute man muss das auch muss
das nach und betont wirklich von diesem
ganzen hilf mir geschwurbel was manchmal
auf einem kanal ja auch drauf nicht
einfach trennen okay weil mittlerweile
ist es ja so wenn man irgendwelche
absurden lebensgeschichten in welche
verwirrten handlungen hört denkt man
sich so ja ja lustig nein das ist
wirklich so passiert das sind echte
schicksal wie da dranhängen und hat
wirklich eine frau ihren mann verloren
an ihre eigene mutter das ist ernst ich
gehe mit jedem problem zu mir sehr gut
unter besten freundinnen ist natürlich
was anderes wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich war das der grund ihre
mutter sich hatte ja nie als sie ja
mutter nee ich bin eigentlich beste
freundin von ihr also weil leute hand
aufs herz sagt mal ehrlich so kennt ihr
geschichten wo ein serbe ein junger was
mit einer freundin hatte und dann aber
auch noch was mit der besten freundin
von mir und er wohl mädchen was mit mit
einem jungen und mit seinem besten
freund hatte das passiert schon eher
die mutter war vergessen dass ihre
mutter ist
als ich mit meinem stiefvater und ein
kern der boden zimmer saß während paul
und meine mutter zehn oder 15 minuten
alleine in der kirche waren
was für ein hund was für ein hund auch
dieser ehe man das ding sorry aber das
kann man nicht in worte fassen ohne
jetzt die situation näher zu kennen muss
man sagen sowohl die mutter als auch ihr
mann der das für menschen müssen dass
sein dass sie so was er in seiner frau
und sie ihrer tochter antun
auch noch drei kinder bekommen weil erst
als lorenz halbschwester sie auf
eindeutige textnachrichten zwischen
mutter und ehemann paul aufmerksam macht
konfrontiert sie beide
dann zieht paul kurzerhand aus und bei
seiner affäre ein
wie möglich ich weiß nicht was ich sagen
soll was also wir gucken mal die
kommentare die kinder die diese
probierten konstellation aufwachsen
können einmal war auch nur leidtun
wahnsinn wie kann man als mutter so
herzlos sein no joke wie dein eigenes
fleisch und blut der dieses kind dem tue
gerade den mann aus spahns kommt aus dir
selbst raus du hast das in deinem
eigenen leib großgezogen und danach so
auch weiß was ich kann
daneben machten und drei kinder mit dem
ja ja ok kleine rote block ist ratlos
wenige wochen später begegnet sie ihre
mutter auf der straße sie war
offensichtlich schwanger und ich
konfrontierte sie damit
[Musik]
der guard das kann man sich wirklich
nicht ausdenken
das kann man so wirklich nicht ausdenken
leute lasst uns bei dieser ganzen sache
wirklich nicht vergessen dass das echte
menschen echte schicksale sind hier es
ist ich betone es noch mal kein hilf mir
eine frau hatte ihren mann verloren und
muss dann auf der straße ihrer eigenen
mutter begegnen und die bratze ist
einfach schwanger von ihrem ex mann
ich würde mich wie talk erst mal kneifen
so etwas denken bin ich gerade haie oder
stofflich oder 18 uhr es wäre eine zu
schwere geistesgestört jetzt so langsam
kommen sowie die puzzleteile zusammen
also es sieht ganz so aus als wäre
einfach ihre mutter einfach wirklich
geisteskrank bist schwanger ja personen
bauch okay bis auf der straße triffst du
deine tochter und du bist schwanger und
dann erzählst du das ist eine liste sei
also keine entzündungen schwellungen
eine woche später haben dann das kind
auf die welt
was für ein hund auch dieser mann ist
heute wirklich einfach eine familie
zumindest mann und mutter voll absoluten
hunden wirklich 100 der mann bekommt ein
kind mit seiner frau und sobald das kind
auf der welt ist muss er ja wirklich bin
ein zeitfenster von wenigen wochen dann
schon die mutter geschwängert haben geht
ja nicht anders wenn die babys mit neun
monaten auseinander auf die welt kommt
so lange trägt man ja ein kind aus
genommen ist es gibt auch ganz lustige
familienkonstellation leute weil der
vater quasi von dem kind was er mit ihr
also mit der die tochter bekommen hat
der ist zeitgleich auch das stiefvater
des kindes
ja weil er quasi später die oma vom kind
geheiratet hat
ja das geht überhaupt nicht mehr die
zeit geschwister sind da wird also auch
gleichzeitig großonkel und großtanten
auf diesem bild sieht man sie mit ihrem
groß auf das muss man auch erst mal
verstehen also lorraine haist die
tochter lauren hat ein kind okay und
dieses kind hat geschwister die von
leons mutter und ihrem ex mann gezeugt
wurden und die geschwister von diesen
kindern haben den gleichen vater aber
die jüngeren geschwister sind großonkel
von der älteren
allein das zeigt auch schon längst hätte
gerade auf dem weg der sollte nicht
beschritten werden sollen berichte in
kontakt mit ihrer mutter völlig ab wie
wir zusammen sind sie aber weiter
gestillt
ich habe nichts zu sagen sie hat alles
gesagt was ich sagen wollte
gibt nichts hat sozusagen also aber im
ernst was wir sicher zu sagen was kannst
du dazu sagen als schuldige als mutter
die die ich kriege die ganzen rollen
nicht mehr zusammen sollte sorry was wir
auch was wir in der situation sagen
kannst du sagen wenn du ehrlich bist du
ja ich bin mir richtig schlechter mensch
ich habe richtig verpackt aber ganz
ehrlich leute solche leute machen es
immer was vor
sie hat gesagt du kannst es nicht
steuern indem du dich verliebst ist
einfach schwach einfach dumm da sieht
man dass das sind einfach asoziale
menschen läuft irgendwas schief ganz
ehrlich leute wahrscheinlich um einige
von euch auch schon mal die situation
gehabt dass ihr euch mit irgend ein
freund oder freundin getroffen hat und
die haben wiederum eine freundin oder
freund gerade durch stationen
da ist schon irgendwie ein bisschen was
in der luft zwischen euch was ihr
zwischen euch und dem partner von einem
freund oder einer freundin so und
manchmal ist das eben so und dann lässt
man einfach dabei und geht nämlich nach
also wird was lernen wir daraus ganz
klare lektion für mich aus dieser sache
ist habt eure mutter gut im auge wenn
ihr einen freund mit nach hause bringt
und fast noch wichtiger ist hier ein
vorgeschlagenes video abchecken main
kanals verbringen ich bin jetzt schon
raus was gut so